Professor, Screenwriting Option, Graduate Program Coordinator, Eric Edson (CSUN - California State University Northridge): Some of the same things and some new
things in stunning surprise to this this
is the climax and and the curtain
dropper for the end of act 2 and a lot
goes I mean the bulk of your movie I
mean act 2 can be 70 pages even more of
of your screenplay and that's why it
deserves a lot of attention and a lot of
thought and planning and we'll get to
that it is the biggest reversal in the
whole movie this is the biggest dramatic
event in your whole movie takes place in
an instant
yes shocks and surprises yes but here
the heroes plan is destroyed that means
at the beginning of act 2 the hero kind
of picks themselves up dusts themselves
off and now they have a very highly
specific and difficult task ahead of
them a goal so they start formulating a
plan and sometimes they start gathering
allies as Campbell says sorting out
enemies and allies in that first section
of act 2 and getting their feet on the
ground forming a plan and moving forward
with it and at toward the end of act 2
yeah you know as as the action is rising
toward the end of the act and the climax
it just just might be possible for the
hero to pull this off it's looking more
and more like it's feasible and then
BOOM stunning surprise two hits and the
plan is totally obliterated the plan no
longer exists and it is called the
heroes darkest hour now it looks like
the hero is finished and let me remind
this it sounds a lot sometimes like I'm
only talking about action movies that's
not the case this in variable degrees is
all genres family dramas this is what
they are - it's just that these things
these contests these conflicts become
between two people one person
to dominate another or convince them of
something all of this is true for all
genres that work that work for audiences
okay and it become it's often called the
heroes darkest hour but I throw this in
because I've got an example coming up to
you again to show you a variation about
five or ten percent of all the movies
that work have a reversal to the
positive in other words by the end of
Act two the hero is kind of down and
then it has to be the biggest reversal
you can't go super down your honor if
you're already kind of down and it goes
up and the big difference is when you do
that and that's fine I mean there's a
lot of romantic comedies and and others
and dramas and other things like that
bridesmaid just like that
Erin Brockovich is like that but what
that means is Act three has to be very
short because the hero is already one C
so the obligatory scene and the day new
mall you get on with those and you wrap
it up and you're you're out your story
is over okay let's take a look at an
example ah not yet this is stunning
surprised two of the matrix okay this is
a more traditional stunning surprise
okay how many have not seen the matrix
okay write it down
alrighty good Megan oh this this was
this was a genre changing movie I mean
we've seen all kinds of movies like it
now and you know the twists and the
concepts that were used in the matrix
but when the matrix came along
it had impact it was fresh these story
ideas the concepts and the way they were
executed they ultimately affected
science fiction forever as a genre so
okay
this is a one hero movie as all of these
are and the hero is neo and he just
saved the life of his mentor Morpheus
and and he was helped by by the love
interest character Trinity and he got
them to a phone booth and that's how the
the the technician on their ship
the Nebuchadnezzar on the the rebels
ship that's how tank gets them out of
the mat and the matrix back on onboard
the ship and he got Morpheus and Trinity
back on the ship
but then the bad person shows up the
adversary Agent Smith shows up and they
have a big fight and it's like a fight
to the draw and neo is making a run for
it but he had the cell phone so he's
still talking to tank and tank is
sending him to another place where he
can be extracted by telephone okay
they're running the robots are running
after him too and ha one of the better
adversaries in film Agent Smith is also
close on his tail closer than neo
actually realizes their cannons are
being shot to zinging and oh yeah this -
mm-hmm this is what I mean about visual
metaphors we we spend a couple seconds
going back to the Nebuchadnezzar which
has also been scientist imal taneous Lee
attacked by these robotic spiders that
are just evil looking through and
through and they are literally tearing
the seals off of it the siding off of it
and they are seconds from storming
inside and killing every human being and
the Nebuchadnezzar
one of the few groups of human beings
still alive in this world what this does
though
what this does is remind us the audience
visually that it's not just neo trying
to save his own life
neo is responsible for all of these
people and that's what makes him a hero
a true hero he is doing yes he's in
danger but he's got to get back for the
protection of other people and they're
the definition of hero there it is
okay he's running down a grungy halt
remember that those of you who have seen
it it's an interesting climaxes visually
quite striking to his runner nice runner
and it's being chasing he hears a phone
ringing behind the door I guess it's
just where tank told him it would be any
better get there fast and he goes up to
the door I wonder why they picked room I
mean
303 usually when a filmmaker puts a
number like that it has significance
maybe it's Trinity's you know -
Trinity's I don't know but the phone is
ringing and he throws the door open oops
agents with Smith is waiting for him
with this hand cannon pointed at his
chest it's over there is no escaping for
it for neo under this circumstance so
but what what wait a minute I'll go back
see he's the small his face is smaller
but look at the expression eyes wide
mouth open stunning surprise one
yes neo you're dead that is pretty
stunning surprise II and he braces
himself to take it like a hero and he's
shot six seven eight times I forget it's
just the way they've sound the juice to
the sound to make those sound like
cannon shots blasting out of that gun
it's very powerful and ouch and then
there's another cut back to the
Nebuchadnezzar to remind us visually we
have to be shown physically and visibly
that's how we get our information in
movies in visual medium we are once
again reminded that if you die in the
matrix you die for real and that's what
this little cut is reminding us and this
is shot Sakura
he's got sparks going on in the
background there was some you know as
the little spider II things are coming
it's like the whole place is falling
apart but there's heavenly sparks also
and Kabang
he keeps pumping them in and there he is
the blood smear on the wall fading going
going and oh yeah poor Morpheus because
Morpheus is the mentor character and he
had all his books you know he was
convinced that the neo was going to be
the one the prophesied person who would
come and save humanity from the machines
right that's a thing running running
through the whole film it's this it's
very religious you know it's like a
Christ metaphor truly the whole film is
and he can't believe it my God how can
you be wrong if neo is dead neo hits the
floor dead he's shot so many times he
has to be dead he falls to the floor he
looks pretty dead and then Agent Smith
has one of his guys check him so he goes
up miss he's gone you know he's as dead
as they can make him right we get it
he's dead
goodbye mr. Anderson okay
biggest reversal in the whole film you
betcha
he takes place in an instant yes shocks
and surprises of course Hiro's plan is
destroyed I would say so if you're dead
that kind of does in your plan and it's
often called the hero's darkest hour it
is somebody's darkest hour there I would
say so so and it was very shocking in
the theaters I don't know if you guys
know the first time I saw it what how
can they just kill off the hero you know
but they did and then did something very
interesting from there but that is tiny
surprise - here is my second hang on
hang on I know it's it's tough just give
me a little longer I go with this one
more example and then I'm gonna show you
some stuff you're not gonna hear
anywhere else so how crazy is that hmm
okay a second example in a completely
different kind of movie in Erin
Brockovich right she's been told she and
Edie the the mentor character the her
attorney have been told they need a
hundred and sixty four or a hundred and
sixty-seven more signatures they're
going to have it decided by a judge
rather than a jury which takes years
they said okay yeah you're gonna
arbitrate with a judge so they find
she's finally got all the signatures she
needs but what she doesn't have is
smoking gun the absolute proof that PG&E
you know Pacific Gas and Electric
because it was based on a real story
that Pacific Gas and Electric knew that
they were poisoning the residents of
Hinkley that is what the smoking gun is
in this particular story and nobody has
come anywhere near that she goes to get
signatures no smoking gun so end of a
very long day but she's gotten her
signatures so she goes to a local bar
and coffee you know coffee shop please
but she's still deeply worried about not
having any smoking gun and then down the
bar there's mister sleaze remember
Charles Embry I think was the
character's name
he's been kind of stalking her for a
little while since the mid point just
this kind of sleazy guy in the
background just looking funny and I and
her funny and he starts to chatter up
the guy tries to start a conversation
this is not a good time place or
circumstance for Erin she needs like
this like a hole in the head
and then he moves in a little closer
whose's down a couple of chairs right
slides closer tries more compliments
says things like I think you're the kind
of person I can talk to you know the
intent it's double entendre of course
you know but it's nice how they play up
to one thing and then reverse it as they
are about to and of course she's trying
to cool him down
show his little interest the reverse
interest the lack of it but he doesn't
let up so she grabs her stuff and she's
taken off and when she's actually
leaving she's not gonna be there to talk
with him anymore
suddenly Charles Embry bursts out with
would it be important to you if I told
you when I worked at the Hinkley plant I
destroyed documents what bingo sounds
like a smoking gun to her right and next
watch what happens next though that is
stunning a surprise too but watch how it
is played out she's getting rattled with
Charles's can you wait with you just
wait here wait here I got to go to the
bathroom I'll be right back I promise
you and she goes running out of the bar
and she goes tries to get her phone and
of course the phone doesn't have any
power and she tries to get change out of
her purse and her purse drops and the
coins fly and finally she's so nervous
and so excited what happened
oh yes okay
and she gets said on the phone the
attorney you know and she gets him all
excited to know well just docked ah
don't push him don't put let him talk
you know people like to tell us and both
of them very very excited and then she
goes back in for a calm conversation
with Charles Embry but the thing is this
these extra moments Susannah grant wrote
the screenplay here of Erin Brockovich
and it is bloody brilliant
she does a number of things little
things like this this is a stunning
surprise but it is very quiet it is
exactly what the hero needs but it's
kind of downplayed and quiet so all of a
sudden we take her excitement as the
hero and she runs off and shares her
excitement with the mentor and the
moment is built to show us the the depth
and breadth of what it means to what
they are doing this is it we have won
and it's added you know to give us a
sense of that rising excitement and very
wisely very very wisely so now back to
this problem the unexpected has struck
wait a minute why does it come back
sorry just give me a couple of seconds
here because I got finally get to the
juicy stuff what wouldn't you know
stunning surprise - the plan is blown
apart
it's the heroes darkest hour as soon as
I get this back up again I got to take
you through this stuff you have been so
patient and you've hung in so well and
yes all of this is going to a
destination and it's an important
destination and I hope you'll be
intrigued by it we shall see
getting warmer hmm the wheel of death I
don't know okay what did you stretch not
much of a stretch nah you don't let let
you get away with much around here okay
this is the summary of type B okay
biggest reversal yes
takes place in an instant shocks and
surprises but here the hero's victory is
delivered you will there is still an
obligatory scene to come and a highly
unusual and extraordinarily emotionally
fulfilling one - when she goes back to
the office and she lays into that in a
comical way lays into the - stuffed
shirt attorneys they've gone into
business with and all kind of stuff so
she gets another victory she gets a
social like victory that is on top of
this one but this is the fact act three
better be short when this happens you
get a short two more hero goal sequences
and we'll talk about that right now
all right take a breath
there are two things that drive all
screenplays that work all of them visual
stories - one is conflict you got to
have lots and lots and lots of it and if
you have weak conflict we're not very
interesting conflict you're going to
lose your audience but the second one is
a bit of an abstraction that haunted me
for years which is you also have to have
change the story flow absolutely needs
to be changing as you go forward it has
to be developing going forward and I
found it impossible to teach that you
know that wasn't either it's one of
those things you use there's an instinct
you have or you don't have kind of thing
but it infuriated me I have I've always
felt that there was something there that
could be teachable so that's when I went
into the weeds and the jungles for a few
years and started watching movies over
and over and over and over trying to
find a pattern in change that had not
yet been codified I know that's pretty
outrageous thing to say and to be
looking for and I was shocked
more than anyone when I actually
realized I was looking at one there is a
pattern to change in these films in the
way they speak to the human mind and
emotions and process this information of
story to make it emotionally fulfilling
there is a unit of change that you can
get your hands on and it seemed to me if
you could truly codify the length and
content of one unit of change you might
really have something in terms of the
most useful tool for outlining a feature
film I've I've ever seen anywhere else
and I try to stay on top
these things define the size and content
of the units of change in successful
screen stories and you can build a more
effective way to write screenplays and
this is a fact and the unit of change
that I found I named hero gold sequences
again because it that refers to actions
rather than abstraction here are the
definitions I'm going to read these I
don't want to you know Muffit so I'm
gonna read it a hero gold sequence we're
talking about a unit of change a hero
goal sequence consists of three to seven
pages of screenplay there is wiggle room
there I've seen him at two pages I've
seen him at nine pages generally three
to seven pages of screenplay
wherein a hero pursues one short-term
physical goal as one step toward
achieving the overarching goal of the
whole story then the hero discovers in
pursuit of that one short-term goal some
form of what I call fresh news some sort
of information or object that they
happen into that is one of them you've
got to have so many surprises for an
audience in history in a feature film it
is one of the small surprises and you
say hmm that's interesting and that
fresh news puts an end to the current
short-term goal and offers up the next
short-term goal and the next hero goal
sequence begins
this is a schematic of it like money I
started it why not you know okay so you
come here you've got a goal you're
searching for the goal and then BOOM
fresh news it is a mini mini mini
stunning surprise
you know mini it's not the big thing and
all of a sudden this goal comes to an
end it's not needed anymore or it's
completed or whatever and boom you're up
to the next level of involvement and
interest and growing tension in the
story here's an example concrete time
gravity how many of you have not seen
gravity ok well I think we're gonna look
at gravity in here because there's so
much to be learned from that film but
here is where it starts
hero goal one in gravity is the ordinary
world of the hero the hero of that movie
is Sandra Bullock who plays dr. Ryan
stone who is in space working on Space
Station because of a deep deep wound
that she received when her four-year-old
daughter fell off of a jungle gym and
died she lost her daughter and her
meaning of life in a freak accident and
she is so profoundly in grief what she
has done is gone as far away from life
and the earth as she can possibly get
into total silence the depth of silence
of space so she is up there she's doing
her work and her goal is to work in
space without thinking or feeling fresh
news and that that sequence also
establishes other members of the crew
and it establishes her her mentor
character the George Clooney character
Kowalski I think was his name
and fresh news after X number of minutes
is Houston
suddenly calls and says abort mission
return immediately
a wide swath of space junk is heading
right at you and now they're scrambling
and trying to get inside with the other
astronauts there I think there's three
of them out there working at the time
and she's caught up in what she's doing
she's trying to finish and reboot you
know she's being focused on that and and
and Kowalski keeps saying get inside now
and you can't move too fast in
spacesuits and all that and fresh news
so get inside the space spacecraft and
return right away and fresh news become
becomes that they don't make it the
debris storm hits and they're right in
its path then that becomes a hero goal
sequence 3 which is do everything you
can to survive the debris storm you see
those are actions that's pile up on each
other this is just one taste I mean this
is I'm gonna have your head spinning
with perhaps you think too much of this
stuff going forward in the course but
this is the ticket guys this is a secret
and here's the weird part this is what I
wanted to get to finally thank you for
hanging in through technical disaster
and all okay
this is what act 1 looks like act 1 just
I'm still astounded but this is true
act 1 in any motion picture that works
for audiences and was a big hit act one
of all of them no matter their genre
have six hero goal sequences in it six
not five not seven six and stunning
surprise one always appears in here ago
c6
always it never fails if the movie
doesn't work then that's not the case I
mean I mean Minh I've done a lot of it
to you you've got to watch bad movies
too but from now on when you see bad
movies I don't want to hear just wow I
didn't like it it stinks you got to tell
me why it stinks
where did they fail in in their mission
to bring you emotion how did they blow
it I want you to be able to spot an you
will soon enough be able to spot exactly
why it didn't work okay and the
weirdness continues here's the graph of
act 2 act 2 is broken in half by the
midpoint sequence the first half of act
2 contains another six hero goal
sequences and the midpoint sequence in
every good movie has a really good
midpoint sequence and that's saying
something because these aren't easy at
all and the midpoint sequence always
appears in here Oh goal sequence number
12 always and in the second half second
half of act 2 as another guess what
another six hero goal sequences and
stunning surprise two always appears in
hero goal sequence 18 not in 19 not in
17 or 16 in 18 in every movie that works
emotionally for audiences act 3 is the
only place it can very act 3 contains
between 2 and 5 hero goal sequences
there's a minimum of 2 because remember
there is the obligatory scene and the
day numa two things are critical and
they have to happen in act 3 and they
each need their own goal sequence so
that's why the minimum is 2
and the maximum is five but hear me
please there are a few really good
movies I mean my favorite romantic
comedy of all time as good as it gets it
has five but it has to wrap up so much
and there are so many important
relationships that have to be wrapped up
in act 3 okay we cut it some slack I am
asking you
short of begging do not go with five
hero goal sequences in your act three
it makes the act too long and your
audience gets Restless it did those
stories or movies we go to and we feel
that they have repent that keeps ending
over and over and it's still ending kind
of thing that is the feeling you're in
danger of creating keep act three short
that is what it's meant to be the
average for a successful Hollywood movie
that is loved all over the world the
average is 21 in other words three hero
goal sequences in act three here's
here's a graph of the entire thing and
here is your challenge this I believe is
extraordinarily good news for you you
now know in advance exactly how much
story your screenplay is going to need
if it is to be a hit with audiences if
it is to affect them and connect with
them emotionally this is what it needs
to be and I mean believe me I'm setting
out to prove it to you and I will prove
it to you this semester in spades that
it's true and it's true across all
genres because this is about you know
this takes us back to Greece this is
about speaking to how your audience
absorbs stoat the ritual of story that's
what it's speaking to but here's the
problem with it I mean
is really I think enormous ly useful and
valuable knowledge but take a look at
the number of little surprises you have
to come up with I've had grad students
you know working on you know some of the
actual writing courses and working on
stuff and I only got four sequences in
the second half of Act two that's all I
can think of that's all I got
can't I just have four in in the second
half of Act two and the old taskmaster
shakes his head no I'm sorry if you
could only come up with four that means
you have to go back in your story to
find why that is true it's telling you
that your earlier story has not been
built in such a way that this can be
provided as you go forward you have to
go back to your basics that kind of
thing so in other words this is your
challenge this is an incredible
challenge to wrestle with so grit your
teeth because that's the facts guys and
here's what it is accomplished by
knowing this which i think is enormous
ly useful it shows you in advance
exactly how much plot you need exactly
how many times you know sequences of
change you're going to have to arrange
and invent one of the things about it
it's in the book and we'll talk about
this stuff too later but for instance
another thing about the hero goal
sequences you cannot repeat you cannot
have two hero goal sequences that are
basically the same if you have one that
is sort of the same of something that
has preceded you then have to add to it
something major that changes it and
makes it unique before you can use it it
shows you exactly how much plot you need
and sometimes this is cold chills at
night because it's a lot of plot it
ensures that the hero will always
be active one of the two or three most
deadly things that killed so many
scripts from near fights is a passive
hero think that the kind of story that
things happen to the hero and the hero
doesn't happen to the story driving the
story forward on their own it doesn't
work like that
if you do this the hero is always active
21 times they are in pursuit of a
physical goal they can never be passive
and what's interesting is that's what
happens in movies that connect with
audiences the heroes are not passive
ever they're doing something that moves
the story forward the story will never
sag that's built in and what we know is
that this is the best you are building
something for the best possible
emotional involvement of your audience
this we're talking psychology here
really that's truly what it is this is
kind of a finger on a certain kind of
absorption of other ritual this is what
brings emotion and pleasure to an
audience and that's that's what you have
to wrestle with oh yeah
and this is good to have a lot of people
talk about this there's a lot of the
grad students go back to their closets
and pull out old stuff you know you got
a half a script here and there you gave
up and in high school there's something
like that add you thought you're we're
going to go somewhere and or you pull
out old scripts you finished a draft
maybe a couple of three drafts but it
just never quite worked didn't ever sail
you know a couple people read it
you know they weren't in to put it away
take it out take this paradigm and imply
you know lay it over your older
screenplay and it will show you exactly
why that script didn't work it'll show
you only two or three interesting things
happen in act one you know well maybe
only three or four interesting things
happened in act two
no that's not enough
I think that's you're finally off the
hook you know okay you're right
say you survived thank you for your
patience through glitches and all and
allowing me to get through this I know
it was a lot to to sit through questions
any questions we're gonna take a break
you finally get to go to the bathroom
and and when you come back it'll be just
us and and and we can relax a bit and
talk about some of this stuff and any
questions you'll want to throw out have
at me okay so thanks break time